as temperatures across europe plummet
thousands of migrants are still stranded
in belarus many have spent weeks outside
in freezing forests near poland they're
still hoping to find a route into the
european union though brussels insists
the block will not accept them dw's nick
connolly met some of those migrants in
the belarusian capital minsk he spoke to
people torn between hope and resignation
this is definitely not where these
migrants imagined their journey into the
eu would end in downtown minsk but with
successful border crossings to poland
and lithuania down to a trickle migrants
stuck here in the belarussian capital
now face a stark choice
risk their lives in sub-zero
temperatures in the forest of the border
region will return to their home
countries empty-handed after paying
smugglers thousands of euros
like the vast majority of migrants here
suleiman is from iraq's kurdish region
he spent weeks in the border forests
even managing to cross to poland twice
one time for several days
came within a hair's breadth of success
i'm in my chamber
we were a matter of meters from the car
that was supposed to take us to germany
five minutes or so when the polish
police caught us
they beat us and destroyed our mobile
phones
they broke my friend's hand and let
their dogs loose on us
it was really scary
[Music]
like many others is sleeping out on the
streets for people like him with expired
visas even the most cramped hostels
charge upwards of 20 euros to sleep on
the floor
nirosh and her mother left iraq with
their entire family in the hope of
finding medical treatment for nirosh's
brother
after 10 days in the forest they gave up
and returned to minsk their male
relatives are still in the forest at
least that's the last they heard
we lost touch with my brothers about 10
days ago maybe their phones are just out
of battery but they could be dead by now
they have no clue where we are whether
we're still here or returned to iraq
the people smugglers told us it would
only take two or three hours to cross
the border towards germany we had no
idea what it would be like
we borrowed money from everyone to come
here to get treatment for our family now
that money is gone and we haven't made
it
but a return to iraq is not something
many here are ready to countenance yet
some say they're already considering
applying for asylum here in belarus
anything but a return to iraq
definitely not a scenario the belarusian
regime envisaged when it opened its
borders to thousands of europe-bound
migrants this summer
meanwhile the exile belarusian
opposition leader svetlana tikanovskaya
has told the european union it must live
up to its values and actively opposed
the authoritarian leader alexander
lukashenko dw's barbara basil caught up
with her in brussels
mr yanovskaya belarus is in the
headlines these days everywhere
but all the focus is on the border
crisis with poland that was initiated by
alexander lukashenko do you feel that in
the sole context you the democratic
opposition are forgotten by the european
union
i'm sure we are not forgotten
i understand that focus was shifted but
it's anyway about belarus and our task
to
open
uh the eyes of the people who is the
reason of this border crisis who is
guilty uh
you know
how how to solve this crisis uh in in
these circumstances you can't solve this
crisis without dismantling regime
because
time after time
dictator will use other methods of
blackmailing the european union so what
do you fear what could he do what else
could he do i mean this was already
fairly inventive everybody was shocked
so what else could he have up the sleeve
since the beginning we told that
only
on the one hand pressure on the regime
political isolation economic isolation
and
support of civil society
positive agenda for future belarus uh
communication about uh free visas for
belarusians
uh you know this comprehensive plan was
very well accepted by pillar of sense
you know
all these consistent and united position
of uh democratic countries will help
bilirubins to to win so
just keep consistency stay united and uh
produce joint uh joint decisions but you
do more want more from the eu for
instance let's look at sanctions you
mentioned the economic side they were so
far fairly timid they haven't really
heard lukashenko so are you pleading for
hard sanctions really cutting off
finance and and cutting off access to
the finance market or just to block
exports what would you want
you know i'm sure that people who
are dealing with sanctions know
what
and who should be sanctioned in belarus
but this policy again should be joined
and and strong i believe me
everybody knows how to deal with the
dictatorship
so how hopeful are you it is
more more than a year that
the big demonstrations took place in
minsk
it seems attention from the outside has
died down the the geopolitical caravan
seems to have moved on in some instances
so you think you can sort of garner
interest again get focused back on you
you know i'm sure that belarus will be a
success story of uh peaceful transition
of power because i know people in
belarus i know thousands of people who
despite of this terror despite of
repressions continue step by step move
forward
i believe bills will be a success story
because
i see how many allies we have in the
world strong countries understand why we
are doing this we share the same values
and you are ready to
fight for these values together with us
and i know that builders will be success
story because
i know myself
i have no choice i can't stop
so as millions of persons can't stop so
uh be with us uh be the part of this
success story
mr kenosha thank you very much you
the deaths of 27 people in the english
channel are deepening tensions between
britain and france the french interior
minister has cancelled weekend talks
with his uk counterpart after
suggestions by the british prime
minister that france wasn't doing enough
to stop migrants trying to reach england
by boat dw correspondent jack parrik
visited the french port of calais and
spoke to people there hoping to cross
the channel
chalau left kierke in iraq six weeks ago
having traveled through turkey greece
serbia and austria he's paid thousands
of euros to get here to france he hopes
he'll soon make it to the uk
i have problems in iraq i have no idea
where my close family are the only
people i have left are relatives in
britain so i'm going there
he's one of hundreds of men women and
children stuck in makeshift camps dotted
up and down the coast
which are regularly destroyed by french
police
for many of them us asking about it was
the first time they'd heard about the 27
people who drowned in the sea after
their boat capsized this week people are
charged 5 000 euros by smugglers if they
successfully cross this 31 kilometers
straight to britain on top of these
waters being dirty and treacherous this
is also the busiest shipping channel in
the world
but until now that hasn't prevented
people from boarding flimsy boats and
trying to make their way to the uk
over 25 000 people have survived the
crossing this year according to uk
authorities
at a nearby center which coordinates aid
support for the refugees they say eu
rules which stipulate a person must
apply for asylum in the first country
they enter are contributing to the
situation
they have their fingerprints in another
country in europe so they can't uh us
apply for asylum in france so this is
the the latch the chance is
trying to
ask for asylum in english this part of
the coast has been the frontline of the
battle between the uk and france on this
issue since the calais jungle camp
sprung up in 2015.
the deaths at sea have returned the
focus but the crisis has never really
been put out
you